y resta simplifica la respuesta y
escríbela como número mixto aquí tenemos
dos números mixtos que queremos restar y
lo vamos a hacer de dos maneras la
primer manera es convertir estos números
mixtos a fracciones impropias
luego restar las fracciones impropias y
el resultado pasarla de nuevo a número
mixto la otra manera es trabajar primero
con las partes enteras restar las y
después trabajar con las partes
fraccionarias y restar las vamos a
empezar la primera manera consta de
transformar estos números mixtos a
fracciones impropias para convertir ocho
enteros dos tercios en fracción impropia
lo que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar
8 por 3 24 + 226
y nos queda 26 tercios
ahora vamos a transformar 50 y 25 sextos
en fracción impropia para hacerlo hay
que hacer 5 por 6 35 35 35
sextos y los estamos restando para
restar sabemos que debemos de tener el
mismo denominador y no lo tenemos pero
si te fijas bien tanto 3 como 6 dividen
a 6 es decir el 6 es el mínimo común
múltiplo de 3 y 6 entonces esta fracción
de aquí la podemos reescribir en
términos de 6 como denominador para
pasar del 3 al 6
tuvimos que multiplicar esta fracción
por 2 2 por 36
entonces en el numerador tendría que ir
26 por 2 es 52
por suerte a la fracción roja no le
tenemos que hacer nada y nos queda 35
sextos y listo ya podemos restar 52
menos 35 52 menos 35 y esto cuánto es 5
parados es 7 y llevamos una y 4 para 5
es 117
y listo pero esto es una fracción
impropia y nosotros queríamos un número
mixto y para hacerlo solamente nos
debemos de preguntar cuántas veces cabe
el 6 en 17 veamos
6 por 2 es 12 entonces el 2 funciona y 6
por 3 es 18 y 18 ya se pasa así que el
número que nos sirve es 2 es decir el 6
cabe dos veces en 17 pero sobran 5
y ahora vamos a hacerlo de la otra
manera
primero nos vamos a fijar en las partes
enteras aquí tenemos un 8 y aquí tenemos
un 5 entonces primero vamos a restar
ocho menos cinco
y ahora vamos con las partes
fraccionarias entonces esto es lo mismo
que más dos tercios
menos
5 sextos
como podemos ver la parte entera es muy
sencilla 85 es 3 y ahora hagamos la
resta de la parte fraccionaria para
hacer la resta ambas deben de tener el
mismo denominador pero ya habíamos visto
que 6 es el mínimo común múltiplo de 3 y
6 así que vamos a reescribir esta
fracción utilizando al 6 como
denominador
para pasar del 3 al 6 tuvimos que
multiplicar por 2 2 por 13 6 entonces
hay que hacer 2 por 2 4 y 2 tercios es
lo mismo que cuatro sextos y nos quedan
esto de aquí
pero hoy tenemos un problema bueno no es
tanto un problema pero observa que
cuatro sextos menos cinco sextos es un
número negativo estamos por debajo del
cero si quisiéramos evitarnos ese número
negativo podemos hacer el siguiente
truco
lo podemos expresar como dos más uno dos
más uno
pero ese uno lo podemos expresar como
seis sextos porque seis sextos es lo
mismo que uno y anotamos el resto de las
fracciones más cuatro sextos menos cinco
sextos esto es lo mismo que dos más
esta parte de aquí
entonces solamente tenemos que hacer
menos
pero
6 45 cuando es 64 10
y nos queda 5 sextos y ya sabemos que 25
sextos es lo mismo que 25 sextos y como
puedes observar de esta manera o de esta
otra obtuvimos el mismo resultado